TREY: TONIGHT AN OPENING ON
SUPREME COURT, CONFIRMATION
PROCESS HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS.
SCALIA WAS CONFIRMED 98-0.
>> AND STEVEN BREYER 87-9
EVEN JOHN ROBERTS CONFIRMED
78-22 BUT THAT IS WHEN IT
BEGAN TO CHANGE BECAUSE OF
WHO WAS IN THE GROUP VOTING
NO, JOE BIDEN VOTED NO,
BARACK OBAMA VOTED NO.
SO DID HILLARY CLINTON.
AND JOHN KERRY, LAST 4
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEES FOR
PRESIDENT VOTED NO, ROBERTS
WAS RATED WELL QUALIFIED BY
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION,
NOT A SINGLE DISSENTING VOTE
BUT NOT ENOUGH FOR THE 4
FUTURE DEMOCRAT NOMINEES FOR
PRESIDENT, THEY OPPOSED
ROBERTS BECAUSE IT WAS
POLITICALLY
EXPEDIANT TO DO SO.
BEING FAIR WAS HARDLY A
MATCH, NOW JOE BIDEN WANTS A
SUPREME COURT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AMERICA.
IF THAT IS TRUE THIS IS A
BRAND NEW POSITION FOR HIM,
IN 1991, JOE BIDEN WAS IN
SENATE WHEN MARSHALL
RETIRED FROM SUPREME COURT,
AND CLARENCE THOMAS WAS TO
BE NOMINATED.
HE JOE BIDEN VOTED NOW.
IF BIDEN HAD HIS WAY THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ALL WHITE.
AND THAT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE
AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN NOW SAYS HE WANTS
A BLACK FEMALE ON THE HIGH
COURT HE OPPOSED A BLACK
FEMALE IN 2005, SHE USED
THAT OLD JIM CROW RELIC
CALLED A FILIBUSTER TO TRY
TO KEEP JUDGE JANICE BROWN
OFF OF THE COURT OF APPEALS
AND MADE IT CLEAR HE WOULD
USE FILIBUSTER AGAIN IF SHE
WERE NORM NOMINATED
FOR SUPREME COURT, AND HE
QUOTED ROBERT BYRD WHILE
OPPOSING.
THAT IS SOME IRONY.
QUOTING A FORMER KLANSMAN
WHILE YOU OPPOSE A BLACK
NOMINEE, THAT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE IN, AMERICA, IN
2001 ESTRADA IS IS
HISPANIC, HE WAS BLOCKED.
13% OF THE COUNTRY WAS
HISPANIC, ZERO MEMBERS OF
THE SUPREME COURT WERE.
BIDEN AND DEMOCRAT DID NOT
JUST KEEP A HISPANIC MAN OFF
OF THE HIGHEST COURT IN
COUNTRY BUT THEY KEPT HIM
OFF THE BENCH BECAUSE HE WAS
HISPANIC, FROM THERE CROWD
WHO NOW CLAIMS THEY WANT
JUDICIARY TO LOOK LIKE
AMERICA,
PRESIDENT BIDEN PROBE MAY
WANT THE COURT TO LOOK LIKE
AMERICA BUT SENATOR BIDEN
DID NOT, I CANNOT THINK OF
ANYTHING THAT LOOKINGS MORE
LIKE A MOTHER THAN BEING A
MOTHER WHILE YOU ACCEL IN
YOUR PROFESSION, MOTHERS
HAVE BEEN BALANCES WORK AND
HOME SINCE THE DAWN OF TIME.
IF YOU WANT SOMETHING TO
LOOKS LIKE AMERICA, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US WAS
BROUGHT INTO A WORLD BY A
MOTHER, WHAT WOULD BE MORE
AMERICA THAN PUTTING A
MOTHER ON HIGH COURT, SANDRA
DAY O'CONNOR AND RUTH BADER
GINSBURG WERE MOTHERS BUT
NEITHER WAS ON THE BENCH IN
2020 WHEN AMY CONEY BARRETT
WAS NOMINATED.
YOU CLAIM YOU WANTED THE
COURT TO LOOK LOOK AMERICA,
THERE ARE 85 MILLION MOTHERS
HERE, NOT A SINGLE ONE ON
SUPREME COURT AT THAT TIME,
SO WHY DID EVERY SENATE
DEMOCRAT OPPOSE PUTTING WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE ONLY
MOTHER, ON THE SUPREME
COURT?
JOE BIDEN HAD A CHANCE TO
MAKE THE COURT LOOK LIKE
AMERICA, BUT HE REFUSED.
HE OPPOSED A BLACK MAN, A
BLACK WOMAN, A HISPANIC MAN
AND A MOTHER, THEY WERE ALL
QUALIFIED AND WOULD
HAVE MADE THE COURT DIVERSE
BUT JOE BIDEN SAID NO.
A AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT
BIDEN SHOULD CONSIDER ALL
NOMINEES.
WHY NOTE LOOK FOR THE MOST
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES, PERIOD
MR. PRESIDENT?
I AM FULLY CONVINCED SOME OF
NAMEDS ON THE LIST WOULD BE
BLACK WOMEN, I COULD THINK
OF SEVERAL RIGHT NOW, ONE
WOULD BE MICHELLE CHILDS
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA, SHE
COULD COMPETE NO MATTER THE
POOL OF APPLICANTS.
SHE WAS ELECTED TO A STATE
COURT JUDGESHIP IN SUCCESS
-- SOUTH CAROLINA A STATE
HARDLY KNOWN FOR QUOTAS AND
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, SHE WAS
THE MOST QUALIFIED NOT
BECAUSE SHE WAS A BLACK
WOMAN.
SHE WAS ELECT Z BY A
REPUBLICAN DOMINATED
LEGISLATURE.
SHE WAS LATER CONFIRMED BY A
VOICE VOTE.
BY THE U.S. SENATE FOR A
FEDERAL JUDGESHIP.
NOT ONE SINGLE SENATOR
OPPOSED HER.
AMONG THOSE SUPPORTING HER,
INCLUDING FORMER
CENTRE JIM DEMINT.
SOME CONSIDERED HIM TO BE
GRANDFATHER OF TEA PARTY
MOVEMENT.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS QUOTAS
OR BELIEVE IN AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION THAT MOTIVATED
SENATOR DEMINT TO SUPPORT
JUDGE CHILDS, SHE WAS
SUPREMELY QUALIFIED.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN PICKING SOMEONE WHO
IS SUPREMELY QUALIFIED AND
HAPPENS TO BE BLACK
THAN
PICKING SOMEONE BECAUSE SHE
IS BLACK.
HE WANTED TO MAKE A
POLITICAL POINT, HE WANTED
TO HELP HIMSELF.
IN THE PROCESS, HE SENSE THE
WRONG MESSAGE.
BLACK WOMEN DO NOT NEED TO
COMPETE NEARLY AMONG
THEMSELVES FOR ONE TO
PREVAIL.
THEY CAN AND SHOULD AND DO
PREVAIL NO MATTER THE
COMPETITION AND I HAVE SEEN
IT COUNTLESS TIMES, YOU
SHOULD LOOK FOR IT YOURSELF.
JOE BIDEN NOW CLAIMS HE
WANTS A COURT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AMERICA DESPITE THE
FACT HE WHIFFED WHEN HIGH
COULD HAVE DONE THAT IN THE
PAST.
IN PROCESS, HE IS REFUSED TO
DO THE ONE THING THAT LOOKS
THE VERY MOST LIKE AMERICA,
PICK THE MOST QUALIFIED
PERSON.
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A BLACK